si es la asamblea general número 77 y la
primera desde que comenzó la pandemia la
que asistirán la mayoría de esos 193
miembros en persona porque se vuelve a
las reglas tradicionales y para poder
participar hay que estar presente
físicamente a excepción del presidente
ucraniano celenski que por obras obvias
razones pues podrá participar de manera
telemática un encuentro de líderes
mundiales que desde luego Está marcado
por esa guerra en Ucrania aunque muchos
mandatarios han hecho hincapié en que no
hay que olvidar otras cuestiones también
muy importantes como el hambre en el
mundo la inflación o el cambio climático
esta semana de reunión de alto nivel
echaremos de menos a personajes
internacionales importantes en la Esfera
internacional Como por ejemplo el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin o el
presidente chino quien No asistirán
tampoco asistirá al presidente mexicano
Eso sí estamos viendo muchas caras
nuevas entre los líderes mundiales sobre
todo entre los líderes latinoamericanos
como las recién elegida cuenta de
Honduras
Xiomara Castro o el presidente de Chile
así como Gustavo Petro presidente de
Colombia quien ha intervenido esta
mañana en el quinto lugar ha dicho que
la guerra contra las drogas Se está
perdiendo y también ha dicho que hay que
defender el medio ambiente y el amazonia
importante también el discurso de Manuel
macron que ha llegado justo después de
ese anuncio de Rusia sobre un referéndum
para anexionar las zonas conquistadas en
territorio ucraniano macron ha dicho que
eso es una provocación y que la
comunidad internacional no lo va a tener
en cuenta ha sido una jornada bastante
interesante cargada de muchísimos
discursos en la que ha arrancado con la
declaración del secretario general de
Naciones Unidas Antonio Gutiérrez
seguido del presidente brasileño Yair
bolsonaro y a quien no hemos visto hoy
como manda la tradición es al presidente
estadounidense Joe biden quien
intervendrá mañana en esta asamblea
general ya que hoy se encontraba de
viaje por el entierro de la Reina Isabel
II